welcome to today's talk today we're
going to talk about building an mlaps
platform and how we've approached that
at hello fresh
um before we get into it Olivia gave me
a very nice introduction so I can keep
the slide short
um uh um I think the only thing that
maybe she didn't mention here is that uh
I'm actually originally from Sweden I've
spent about half of my life there uh
both in education and in work and the
other half in the U.S and my educational
path I've started in electrical
engineering like she mentioned kind of
on the hardware side then moved over
into the software space during my PhD
years and went into the AI space from
there so so I think that's the only
thing that wasn't mentioned so let's get
into the talk so this talk it's not
about promoting an mlap service it's not
about telling you
how to do mlapse or what the right way
to mlapse is it's uh AI leadership talk
it's it's about the why behind
um how do you make good decisions when
building a platform system when building
an mlap system the tools aren't that
important because the tools are rapidly
changing and they're changing all the
time but what is important is the
Frameworks for the decision making and
kind of the how do you make intelligent
Intelligent Decisions in this space so
really focus on the why not the how or
the what
and I'm going to show you a lot of
information here today
um and uh this is the work of many many
people uh many talented people and I
want to thank them for all their
contributions uh this is not a work of
uh Eric just producing all this content
that you're about to see so I want to
acknowledge that
this talk is really divided into three
parts uh first we're going to kick
things off with a quick primer on ML Ops
just so uh we all have have a baseline
understanding of what it is and why it's
important then we're going to talk about
hello fresh in a section I call
interesting things about hello fresh and
then we're going to take the first two
sections and combine them and talk about
mlaps at hello fresh the first two
sections are going to go pretty quickly
um because the meat and potatoes is
really in the third section here and I
want to make sure that we get to that so
we have
time to dive deep there
okay so let's talk about ml Ops uh this
is just kind of skimming the surface to
give you a quick taste of it uh it's not
really an in-depth
um uh education on ML apps so uh so be
warned I think a good way to think about
mlops and understand why it's important
is to frame this in the context of where
most of us start as data scientists and
ml practitioners
so I think one many of us have gotten
started we we start off by collecting a
data set online maybe we upload it to
the cloud or locally to our computer
and we start working on a notebook we
explore the data we do our feature
transformation we train our models we
evaluate the models against different
metrics uh finally we feel like we have
something that's given us pretty good
results and maybe we save the models we
saved inference results and we're
feeling we're feeling really good about
it ourselves we feel like we have nailed
a sub segment of machine learning
um I think that's a great start but
um machine learning and at a large
company in a production environment
looks very different
um what you know quote the real world
looks like is that in real life you'll
have multiple data sources you'll
probably have a data Lake a data
warehouse you might have streaming data
um you have data coming off of your
product website or app
um you'll have probably large amounts of
data you know hundreds of millions of
rows many gigabytes maybe terabytes of
data
you're going to take all that data and
you're going to try to transform it and
make it useful for your machine learning
models you're going to probably instead
of doing that right in your notebook
you'll probably do ETL as a service uh
maybe using one of these Services here
and you'll start training probably in
practice multiple models probably not
just one model you'll do multiple models
probably with distributed computing
because you're managing so much data and
you want to move faster
in the real world you see a lot of
situations where you have nested models
where a first set of models feed
Downstream models or their input to
Downstream models and eventually you are
going to serve those models either by
batch or real time and you want to do
some monitoring on them
so you can see that the real world looks
much more complex and there's many more
things that can go wrong here uh
everything from pipelines breaking you
have data sources that are changing so
you might have data quality issues you
have a lot of orchestration of
infrastructure that needs to happen you
want to observe your model quality to
make sure that your models Don't Drift
and uh you know that they're accurate
and they're doing what you intended them
to do
so there's uh and on top of all of that
you know if we were to just do all of
this manually this is a lot of work and
your data science team can basically
spend all their time in maintenance mode
I never have the opportunity to um to
produce new models so um that's why we
really want to try to automate things as
much as possible especially the
deployment of new models
and
excuse me I'm battling a cold here so
I'm going to be coughing a little bit
throughout this presentation
if we we zoom out and look at the goals
of ml Ops
I think they're threefold the first is
faster deployment of retrained models
into production
the second is faster experimentation and
model development we can often achieve
that through sharing our features
through a feature store across an
organization
and the third is model and data quality
assurance so checking the data quality
at the source and checking the model
quality uh in production to make sure
you don't have model drift
I'm going to show you two images here uh
just to kind of frame the problem a
little bit more if you're new to ml Ops
um here's a slide this is from Google on
mlap's technical capabilities
um and there's two parts to this you
have foundational capabilities that are
really part of any it system where you
need infrastructure security and privacy
and artifact repositories
and on top of that you have your mlops
capabilities
um kind of starting with these two gray
boxes you want a artifact and metadata
repository to do things like you know
track data source versioning model
versioning hyper parameters that you're
using a model uh
um uh model tracking
and on top of that like I mentioned you
probably want a feature store to be able
to share the features that you create
across your organization to speed up
creating new models
and in between that you see all these
different uh capabilities that you can
have what's important is you know it's
important to remember you don't need
every capability here what you need kind
of depends on your organization and the
types of models that you're serving and
you don't necessarily want to go out
there and build a system that has all
this stuff right off the bat it'll take
a long time you'll probably design your
system incorrectly that you want to take
more of an iterative approach to where
you start pretty small with a couple of
these and keep adding functionality
iteratively
and just to illustrate what a pipeline
can look like for those who haven't seen
it here's just a sample architecture
where you have multiple data sources
like it talked about and you'll probably
be doing your ETL transformation
um in this case we're doing it inside of
a feature store once you have your
features you you can store them in that
set feed to restore
and if we move over to orchestration we
pull the data out of there maybe we're
pulling multiple feature set we need to
do some data preparation and merge all
those features together into our final
data set we can train it and train our
model and we do an evaluation if the
model is performing better than what we
have in production we will deploy it and
when we deploy it we can do a multiple
ways depending on on the needs of
whoever's consuming the model whether
it's online API endpoints batch or
streaming inference jobs and we'll
probably do monitoring of that model as
well
if uh we don't promote it if it doesn't
perform better than what we have in
production we'll archive it we'll
analyze it we'll retrain the model with
new hyper parameters and try to uh get
better performance out of it and kind of
go through that that training Loop once
again so this is just an illustration
not all pipelines look like this it
depends on on the the needs of your
organization but I think this is just a
good mental model to have in the back of
your mind as we go through this talk
okay I'm gonna grab a drink here
foreign let's move on to the second part
interesting things about hello fresh
so hello fresh is a meal kit company we
are I like to think of us as
a combination of Spotify mixed with
Amazon and that we are a
subscription-based company but on the
other hand we have these giant
warehouses where we create our products
and we ship these boxes off all over the
world
we are the largest meal kit company in
the world uh 7 out of 10 meal kits is a
hello fresh meal kit and our mission is
to change the way that people eat
forever and the way that we do that is
really through these four dimensions we
have cost effective meals
um the majority of them are fairly
healthy
uh they taste quite great we have a good
quality product and uh we are more
sustainable than the conventional I go
to the grocery store and buy your
groceries
and bring them home
and the way that we do that is that
traditionally this is what your food
supply chain looks like uh you'll have
many middlemen here wholesalers
warehouses and supermarkets before the
food finally reaches your plate we get
rid of all those middlemen we Source all
of our our food directly from the
producer
direct to our warehouses we put these
meal kits together and we deliver them
directly to you and that results in more
freshness you can get your food faster
and we have less waste in our in our
supply chain compared to the traditional
supply chain so that's kind of the the
secret sauce and what we do
some interesting statistics here
um we have 8 million active customers
worldwide in 2022
almost 67 million meals uh delivered
we're operating in 18 countries we're
going to be 19 hopefully by the end of
the year uh almost 600 million orders
placed this year and here you can see
our our head count growth
um
in the past uh you know almost 10 years
you can really see that it's taken off
exponentially from around 2017 it's
really taken off
and that's part of our our Emma lot
story that I'm going to be telling uh in
just a bit
real quick where we operate we're in
North America
um and Western Europe as well as
Australia and New Zealand and
um Japan and we're trying to expand to
Spain by the end of the year and I think
we actually just expanded to Ireland uh
so that one should be penciled in as
well
okay so I want to talk a little bit
about what our our Tech organization
looks like because that plays into our
mlap story of course
so let me give you a quick snapshot of
how we're structured on the tech side
um you can basically divide up our our
uh our tech department called flow Tech
into five areas growth marketing uh
product assortment
foundations and Technology operations
and finance and Analytics
uh I sit on a team called Global AI uh
it's um within this group called
decisions so these are all alliances and
we're using the Spotify model so we have
alliances underneath alliances we have
different tribes and within the tribes
we have different squads which is just
our scrum delivery team
but my my uh Team sits here were the
largest
um uh data science group at the company
but then we have all these different
data science teams in these uh different
alliances we have teams within data
within food uh within growth within
operations
and if you oversimplify the structure of
the organization you can break the data
science teams into really two different
buckets I think we have marketing type
data science teams that work on
marketing applications
and then we have supply chain and
operations type teams that work on that
side of the house and they can also
slice the teams between North America
and international I should also mention
that you know we are a German founded
company the company's based out of
Berlin so
um a big part of our staff sits there
the the larger part and the other half
is kind of here in North America and
there's some exceptions to that of
course
um but above all this is my team kind of
this overarching team global Ai and to
oversimplify what we do I would call
ourselves a platform team we have
different types of platforms that we
build one of them is the mlaps platform
but we also have models that we we build
as well but just simplify this
conversation we'll call ourselves a
platform team and our goal is to really
enable other teams throughout the
organization to help them build models
faster
all right so let's talk about our our
data science Journey as a company so uh
once again bringing back our head count
chart here
um like I mentioned we had really uh
explosive growth here from about 2017
and things really took off during the
pandemic for us a lot of people became
really interested in cooking and wanting
to learn how to cook uh so we were
really
um spending a lot of our time opening up
new distribution centers to accounting
for that growth uh and what happened was
we started having more and more data
science teams grow throughout our
organization
these data science teams they didn't
have the best of communication with each
other sometimes we had a little bit of
overlapping
um scope between teams there wasn't
great communication when it came to
tooling people developed their their
tooling pretty independently of each
other
um no teams really had mature end-to-end
pipelines and this resulted in a lot of
problems for the teams
so some of the issues that we saw was
like I mentioned we had inconsistent
tooling we didn't have company-wide
standards but on the data science side
we had scaling difficulties especially
when we were trying to get our models
across different geographies we had
related reliability issues with our data
pipelines and ETL and we accumulated a
lot of tech debt
um I think one of the reasons for this
is partially the the
organizational model that we have chosen
the Spotify model uh it's in you know
the whole point of the model is that you
have autonomous teams and you want them
to move fast and that's awesome and
great and I believe in it but on the
other side of the coin you you develop a
lot of these problems at some point as
an organization you have to take a step
back and decide to to deal with them
and I think we're at that point right
now where I say that we're kind of going
through our awkward teenage years as a
data science organization we're trying
to go from you know we have some pretty
good stuff today but we want to be a
world-class machine learning
organization and a lot of the tools and
platforms that we're building today is
gonna are gonna help our teams get there
okay so that was hello fresh
and now we're going to talk about we're
going to combine those two things and
we're going to talk about ml apps at
hello fresh
so let's dive into it so how did we
approach building our mlaps platform
well uh is really took a similar
approach to any engineering problem or
or the way any product manager would
look at this problem uh it's all about
understanding the problem space first uh
so the first thing we we have to do is
really understand our customers and what
are the their pain points and what are
their needs
we have to define a product division we
have to talk about what we want to
create we want to talk about what we
don't want to create as well
and once we have created those two
things we can go into the solution space
we can get into things like tool
selection uh figuring out what our
platform is going to be built on and
then get into the development phase
one of the problems that I see Tech
teams do is that sometimes if they're
just engineering lead you'll often see
teams just jump to points three and four
and just dive into tool selection and
development and you might get into a
situation where you try to create the
Swiss army knife and try to handle every
possible hypothetical situation that you
think might arise but you don't really
understand the problems that you need to
solve very well so you'll over engineer
you'll you'll
spend a lot of time and ultimately not
solve the problem that your users are
facing so the most important part is
real to spend enough time on the first
two points and we actually spent a lot
of time here it's many months just to
understand and to Define what we wanted
to create and if you're looking to build
a platform I would advise you to to do
the same spend a lot of time on on this
space before you start building
something
so I'm going to talk about those four
points and kind of many subsections here
and kind of go into details about how
did we approach each one and give you
some Frameworks and some tips in each
section
so how did we understand our users so
pulling back our little uh org
illustration here
um we asked kind of obvious questions
that you would think that we would ask
uh first of all uh when I started back
in at the beginning of the year here
um we didn't really have a good
understanding as an organization of what
all the data science teams were and what
they were working on there were pockets
of knowledge that understood parts of
organizations
but there wasn't that kind of top level
understanding of even what everyone was
doing
so we really had to ask you know who are
the data science teams and what problems
are they working on and just go around
and talk to them uh to get and kind of
map that out
and it sounds like a very trivial thing
but when you're you're in a large
organization with a thousand people in
your Tech organization that actually
took takes quite a bit a while to to map
out the space and and learn where
everybody is and what they're working on
the third thing to be asked is we wanted
to map out what model architecture is
and what data they're using in their
models
we want to understand what kind of
tooling they're using today what do they
like what do they not like what their
existing tooling what problems do they
have
and then we also had to understand you
know what are the data roles within the
company and uh what's our definition for
them and who should we be building the
system for
uh once again also sounds like kind of a
silly question but once again in large
organizations
um you know and especially being a
company that operates in Europe and the
US it's easy to have different
definitions for different types of roles
across a across a organ organization
um so I'm going to go through each of
these in the next couple slides and kind
of show you how we approached each of
these problems starting with uh the
bottom one here
so we mapped out different roles across
our organization and I think an
industry-wide problem that you we have
and machine learning is that let's say
you know let's say your product data
scientist and at hello fresh but you go
to a different company
um product data scientists might need
something different there and you might
have different job responsibilities I
think you see that pretty commonly
across the board here for all these
roles so we have a kind of a
standardization of job description
problem I think in the machine learning
industry
that hopefully will will get better over
time
but what we did was we we drew out this
axis here
um starting with less technical roles on
the left and as you advance to the right
you you get into more technical roles
and we created these oops excuse me we
created these definitions for the
different roles and we said that well we
want to build a platform for our data
scientists and ml engineers and in the
hello fresh world that means a data
scientist is somebody who who builds and
creates the models and the ml engineer
is somebody who takes those models and
productionizes them
the
hopefully this is not in the way
uh is can everybody see the the sliders
this little thing blocking it there let
me see if I can get off the screen there
we go
um the next thing we want to do is to
map up the maturity of the existing
antelops in our our company and what we
did was we went around and talked to
teams of course what their pipelines
looked like but then we wanted to
visualize it so we created this little
framework where we plotted several
models across our x axis up here we
plotted the major components from a mlop
system on our y-axis over here and we
also came off with definitions for you
know what does it mean to be mature in
each of these components and by doing
that then we could score each model
um either as a mature intermediate or
mature and create this heat map of of
what was going on across our
organization
and a couple things pop out right
um we noticed that we're definitely
weaker
on the back half of our pipeline from ml
deployment to drift detection
we also we also noticed that you know no
one really has model optimization uh or
distributed hyper parameter tuning
um no one's really doing that today so
we decided that okay that's nice to have
but maybe that's the secondary problem
that we'll address later let's focus a
lot of our effort on this part right now
from ml deployment to drift detection
and we also notice that we're not really
fully mature in any of these areas I
think that really popped out as well
the next thing that we wanted to do was
to
understand the types of models that we
had in our organization
so creating a similar plot you you lay
out your models here on the x-axis then
we looked at things like ML
orchestration and ml architecture for
those models
um so starting at the top we laid out
the the data structure we noticed that
most of our models are using tabular
data we looked at things like retraining
Cadence the inference Cadence and the
deployment types for these different
models started seeing patterns there
and then we looked at the ml
architecture so the model type we do a
lot of boosted trees in our organization
we looked at the Target and we looked at
the complexity as well and what's plot
does it it really helps you later on
when you get into the tool selection
phase to look at tools that can support
these types of models so it really kind
of helps you once you get to that step
to make good decisions for Tool
selection
um the third thing that we did was to
look at the different tools across teams
that and what tooling they're using a
similar plot again model on on the
x-axis we have our 10 categories for our
mlaps Pipeline on the right and what you
do is just plot out the different tools
that people are using now this plot
looks pretty stupid because I've had to
uh White Label uh the the chart and not
show the different tools that the teams
were using
um but you get the idea if you take this
and you color code it you'll start
seeing patterns and I'll give you a good
indication for what tools should you
probably consider keeping versus which
ones maybe you should you know consider
replacing which ones are one-off tools
so just kind of create that that
visualization for you which is very
helpful helpful when you have a large
organization and many models to consider
then the next thing that we did was to
look at ourselves in a ml maturity
framework so just kind of a
self-assessment of where are we today
and when we started this journey uh
early this year we were somewhere we're
probably at the beginning of one here of
uh devops but no ml Ops and this
framework comes from Microsoft you can
find it at this link down here
um and right now we've we're basically
launching our ml platform I think we'll
get most of our models on there by next
summer
um and we expect to be all the way up to
level four by then
um but the idea is that you can
continuously kind of come back to this
Frame this framework and assess where
you're at and make sure that you're
making good progress towards being a
mature ml Ops company
and then another helpful helpful thing
that we did early on was to identify
different uh sample models and Sample
use cases that we could use during the
development phase and the reason I think
why this is very helpful to do up front
is
um if you don't do it uh you'll probably
spend a lot of time searching for
representative models once you get to
that uh development phase or you'll come
up with
um a model that you think is a good
representation of what your company does
but it maybe it's not you know maybe
it's just a Mickey Mouse model that
doesn't actually reflect what you guys
really do as a company so I think it's
good to pick out a couple different
style of models and halos in your back
pocket
all right let's talk about uh defining
the vision for the platform
so this is the model maturity framework
that we came up with
um here you'll see these 10 different
envelopes categories that you saw on
those
heat charts a couple slides ago
and this is basically the input what we
used for assessing how mature each model
was at for each component of the
pipeline
um I think the these questions are a
combination of Frameworks provided by
Microsoft and AWS that we used as
inspiration for this
um but the right questions for for each
component will really depend on what
your organization needs so this isn't I
wouldn't use it as a source of truth but
it's a good starting point
um just to illustrate like some of the
questions that we were asking for let's
take feature engineering for example
um so for us to be a mature company in
terms of feature engineering we want ETL
pipelines that are automated pipelines
should be version controlled feature
preparation should occur in a future
store future feature services are
registered in the in the feature store
and model features are pulled from the
feature store so that's just an example
I'm not going to go through all of these
but I think this is basically what you
want to create so you have a source of
Truth to kind of go back to and
um and Benchmark against just so you
know that you're mature in each category
the next thing that we made was a mlap's
platform Vision so our vision was to
create an end-to-end tool that would
automate the mlap's pipeline creation
process and speed up the
productionization of models by
standardizing mlops across slopefresh
for the majority of our machine learning
models I think the important part here
is actually this these last couple words
for the majority of our machine learning
models so we're acknowledging that we're
not going to be able to create a system
that's going to work for every single
model that we could possibly create as
an organization that we want to focus on
the majority of them and this kind of
implies that we we need more than one
product right
um this led us to to adopt the 80 20
rule where we said that okay we think
that we can automate 80 of the models uh
within our our company
um the 20 that we can't automate those
should be very easy to create
um using a different tool
so fully automated 80 easy to create for
the other twenty percent
and that led us to what our product
stack should look like
so here's a visualization of our our
product offering
and I think I'll start here at the
bottom and work my way up
so at the bottom we have our service
layer these are the the main components
for the ml Ops pipeline registry a
feature store orchestration inference
endpoints and monitoring
on top of that we have an integration
layer
um this basically just enables you to
communicate from our our products down
to the individual tools that we're using
and and configure them however you want
on top of that we have two different
products that we're offering uh the
first is called spice rack and it's a
low level API that's designed for our ml
Ops engineers
the ml Ops Engineers that what they
really care about is configurability
they want to be able to go in here and
tweak every mlops tool that we have
provided but we also want to make their
lives faster and simpler right and the
way we do that is by treating spice rack
is really a wrapper that goes around all
these different tools that we are using
rather than learning
um you know let's say rather than
learning many different Services you
know five six seven different tools
you'll just have to learn the API
classes for uh for one tool the other
benefit that it adds is that we can
really speed up
um the time it takes to create a
pipeline and the way we do that is by
providing templates for popular pipeline
architectures that occur across our
organization so so really the
combination of having that wrapper
around other tools that simplifies the
use of those tools and the use of
templates that's going to accelerate
Development Across the organization
so that's for our our most technical
Persona the mlaps engineer and on top of
that we have another tool called or
another product called mlaps Factory and
this is a high level API designed for
data scientists and data scientists they
you know they don't necessarily care as
much about being able to configure every
single component they do want to
pipeline but they want to move quickly
and an idea here is that we'll create a
product where if you meet a certain set
of input specifications with your model
then this API will build out a full
end-to-end mlaps pipeline for you
you won't be able to configure that
pipeline or you'll have very limited
ability to to configure it but the
trade-off there is that you know maybe
you'll be able to spin up the
infrastructure for this Pipeline and 10
15 minutes
um today it takes our our Engineers
about four weeks to build out a pipeline
that's not even a full end-to-end
pipeline like the ones that I showed you
in that introductory section for for ML
Ops but that's just a pipeline that has
certain parts of of those components
that I showed
um and with spice rack we think that we
can get uh the time to build a pipeline
down to less than a day and we're hoping
with ML apps like I said I think under
15 minutes is the goal just to spin up
the infrastructure once you meet those
uh input specifications
so that's kind of how we're thinking
about it taking a multi-api tiered
approach to address different customers
with with different user needs
and here's just an illustration of of
how spice rack is solving some of these
problems that we called out earlier of
inconsistent tooling lack of Standards
scaling problems reliability and Tech
debt
um the benefits of the platform it is
going to accelerate ml model deployment
and development
it's also going to be more reliable in
terms of your etls and pipelines it's
going to have scalable infrastructure
it's going to be easy to use and it will
standardize the ml infrastructure across
the organization
so it really addresses a lot of our pain
points as a company
okay so that was the vision for what we
wanted to create now let's talk about
how do we choose the tools that are
going to enable this vision
so there are a couple of pain points
when choosing tooling within ml Ops
um there are a lot of services out there
last week I read an article I think
there's about nearly a hundred companies
in the ml apps space right now
some of those companies cover end-to-end
pipelines some of them cover just one
component of the pipeline some of them
cover a couple different components and
it's just really confusing to understand
who does what right now and it seems
like new companies that are popping up
every month
um so we have that very confusing tool
selection there are many options out
there
and the third thing that's complicated
is it's really hard to understand how
these tools integrate with each other
it's not just what do the tools do but
how well do they work together
and I think what I'm seeing is that a
lot of companies claim that oh our tool
is really easy to use and it's easy to
integrate with this or that but I think
a lot of companies are over promising
right now in terms of how well things
integrated and how easy it is uh to do
that integration is what I've found so
what I'm saying is you don't really know
um what you're getting until you take a
tool and you try to integrate it with
something to find out really how well it
works
I'm doing tool selection you can really
it's easy to get lost in the weeds and
uh see someone's radius of your hand
I'll write your question down I'll take
the questions at the end here uh if you
don't mind
um it's good to set up a set of
principles uh when doing tool selection
uh it gets pretty confusing when you
start getting into it and it's easy to
get lost in the weeds and the details so
our team came up with this uh set of six
principles that that guided our decision
making we chose we wanted to have open
source tools over closed Source we
wanted to use apis over gui's or
graphical user interfaces we wanted
lightweight apis over integrated tools
to avoid vendor lock-in
uh fewer tools were considered uh better
um
well asterisk to that we just didn't
want one end-to-end tool because we
didn't want to be locked into one
technology but at the other end of the
spectrum we don't want 10 tools either
so we want something in the middle that
you know find that sweet spot between 1
and and ten right
we acknowledge that we want to build a
system that's practical and get it to
Market quickly over something that's
perfect we don't think that we can ever
ever get to perfect we acknowledge that
so we want to move quickly and just get
something out there that people can use
and keep iterating on that
and then python is really important to
us we are a python organization uh and
and all tools have to have that as the
common denominator
so there were two different ways that we
chose tools and I'm gonna I'm gonna
share both of those ways the first tool
that we chose was our feature store and
and that's really the backbone to our
entire mlap system and a very important
component and we wanted to take a very
scientific approach to selecting this
tool so we went through these four
different steps the first one was to
identify the needs for that feature
store the way we did that was to have an
agile session with a couple different
data science teams they would write down
questions and do kind of a mind map for
you know what do they think are
important questions to consider for a
feature store or what are important
technical needs then we would kind of
mind map and cluster those ideas
together and rewrite them as questions
we group those questions into different
categories categories were things like
you know Tech questions security cost
user experience short and long term
strategic considerations
and then we would prioritize those
questions as low medium or high and
those are really weights because
ultimately what we're doing is uh we did
an evaluation we had narrowed down the
field to three different vendors and we
did a technical evaluation on those
platforms uh scored them quantitatively
uh when possible sometimes we did
qualitative evaluations especially on
things like user experience we're really
comparing between two different
platforms how easy it is to do something
But ultimately we ended up with numeric
scores for everything we waited them
with uh the priority and we came up with
the total Max score that we could
compare the different Services
um to
and the output looks like this where you
have the three different vendors
ultimately we chose a vendor called
techton and uh you can see the Mac score
down here and what percentage they got
and uh here's a kind of a visualization
of some of the key features of the
platforms but what what's really good
with this approach is that it's very
scientific it's very structured it's
easy to communicate to your C Level uh
how you went about testing the platforms
and why one is better than the other and
it really removes that personal bias and
I've found I've been involved in a
couple different platform selection
engagements as a consultant and I found
that there's a lot of personal bias that
goes into these decisions depending on
what people have used in the past and
where people are coming from and we're
trying to get rid of all that bias and
just
select the tool based on its Merit
now
the downside with this this method is
that it does take up a lot of time it's
a very rigorous method and and thorough
but it takes some time so that's kind of
the trade-off
so we want to ask the question well we
have to make a lot of tooling decisions
and how do we scale this process to make
all the tooling decisions that we have
to make if we spend as much time we'll
spend two three years uh just deciding
on what tooling to use without even
building anything so how do we move
faster
well to move faster first we had to
understand what the mlap's industry
landscape looks like and we had one of
our Engineers do a very thorough mapping
where he looked at about 60 different
companies and grouped them into uh these
different categories that they operate
and and once again did just a visual
heat map of of where they operate and
what they're good at and that helped us
narrow the field down to 12 to 15
different vendors that we would look at
very seriously
and rather than doing a one by one
evaluation we thought Let's uh do a
hackathon and evaluate many different
services at the same time because once
again it's not just about the tool
itself but it's really about how do the
tools integrate with each other uh and
you want to find that secret you know
that that's a special sauce combination
that's just right in the works for your
organization
so we took uh two levels to this one was
the the integration analysis
uh we built these five different Stacks
with different uh tools and services and
mapped them you know across what parts
of the pipeline do they cover
um from this evaluation we basically
figured out which vendors we should
contact which tools do we want to move
on to the next round and evaluate
Hands-On and which ones should we
de-prioritize and not consider
then in the second round uh we evaluated
a different pipelines here we created
five different pipelines of
removed the labels here I'm not sure
what we were doing but
uh basically like I said what we're
looking for is that integration and how
well the tools worked at the same time
and the way this works is you you build
a couple pipelines you you figure out oh
I like these tools for the first part of
my pipeline I like those tools for the
the back half and then in the next round
let's combine those two and try that out
and then you're like you learn a couple
new things you're like okay that worked
out pretty good but let's swap this
service out for the next one and do
another round of testing and after a
couple rounds of of experimentation like
that you ultimately end up with a
pipeline that that works pretty good
that you're happy with and that can be
kind of your MVP pipeline that you can
start with so it was a faster way to
move
still fairly scientific but but there is
a trade-off there that you are not quite
as thrill as the other technique
um just a couple points here for uh
doing tool selection
once again you define your guiding
principles early that's your roadmap
when you get into the actual hackathon
or the valuation is super easy to get
lost so it's very nice to have those
those principles to fall back to
everybody has an opinion and especially
data scientists and I realize that I'm
talking to probably I need a data
scientist right now but uh data
scientists are very opinionated and have
a strong belief in which tools are
better and which ones are worse
um to get around that we did two things
we used a small team to evaluate these
different tools and we did this in
stealth mode once we had gotten inputs
from other teams just to be able to move
quickly and make decisions quickly
I'm a strong believer that the tool
selection is not a democratic process
you collect your inputs you figure out
what what you need to do then you go
evaluate things and you make decisions
quickly
um and when you're doing that you want
to take that scientific process to
remove bias
and you also want to time box your
approach because you can you can spend
forever on this right so Define what's a
reasonable amount of time to evaluate
tools depending on how many you're going
to look at draw a line in the sand do as
much work as you can within that period
and then make a decision and move on
all right
last section here on development
so um we came up with a couple of
different design principles when we
headed into the development phase we we
don't want to be locked into one tool
and the idea here is that this MLS
industry is evolving so quickly so many
new companies all the time there are
going to be better tools that come along
maybe in six months maybe next year but
we don't want to be locked into one tool
and not be able to get out of it so we
want to build a system where the user
doesn't really see what's under the hood
they shouldn't care they just interact
with the the product that we're creating
the platform that we're creating and we
can swap the components in and out and
the only difference that they should see
is better performance they shouldn't see
a difference in the API classes that
we're creating
we also want to have very simple and
intuitive API classes not a lot of weird
language which we tend to have and and
the envelops the world
and you shouldn't have to start from
scratch every time we want to work from
templates as much as possible
um
and the user experience uh looks like
this for spice rack think of it as you
know it's an API wrapper but it really
works more like like a python Library
like scikit-learn that you pip install
the library at the beginning of your of
your notebook you can either call up the
different classes that we've created but
the more likely scenario is that you'll
you'll go to GitHub and you'll download
load one of the templates that we've
created for popular pipeline
architectures at flow fresh
they're pre-populated you just go in
there and tweak a couple things to make
sure that you're pulling data from the
right data set you're using the right
model architecture you set in your
evaluation metrics and so on once you've
done all that you you run it you build
your pipeline
and uh it should be pretty fast to move
on this platform it consists of these
five major components we have what we
call experiment manager
it's really like an artifact management
tool of
um uh tracking and storing you know data
sets features models hyper parameters
all that kind of good stuff and then
it's also a promoter in there where it
will take your model it will come it
will compare it to a a golden data set
it'll see how it performs compared to
the existing model and production and
the side of it it should promote it to
production or not
then we have two deployment components
our our batch predictor which is our our
bets uh batch tool then we have our rest
end deployer then we have a monitoring
component and a drift detector
and this is kind of the point in the
presentation where I would pull out a
fancy video and show you an awesome demo
of this in action I do have that video
but unfortunately I'm not able to show
it so and uh in lieu of that I'm going
to kind of talk through some of the key
steps of using the platform at a high
level just to give you a sense for uh
what a ml engineer would actually do
so uh the platform uh it seems that you
have ingested your model features into
this feature store so the first thing
that you need to do is configure your
data sets to pull the data from the
feature store
the second thing you do is set up the
your model configuration so what you
know what type of model architecture are
you using
thirdly you would configure your
experiment tracking so that artifact
management and uh kind of the the rules
for the model promotion uh and the data
set for the model promotion
then we would select the deployment type
is it a batch or is it a rest endpoint
um we would configure the back end after
that we offer different types of
different compute resources for for
different situations
you'll set up your orchestration after
that using our pipeline orchestration
tool and then we kind of sandwiched that
all together in what we call the model
specification and it's really just the
instruction set that calls out these
could be six different lines to tie
everything together and one nice tight
little instruction set
and if we just visualize this this is
what it looks like that you create this
model spec with those six different
steps we read your data set and pull the
data from the feature store
train and validate our model we decide
if we should promote promote it or not
we deploy it either by rest endpoint or
our batch score and then we do our our
model reporting or our model monitoring
to report performance or drift
okay we're almost there so a couple of
things uh I said this early on but your
MEP doesn't need everything right these
are the 10 things that we want to do but
it's not what we are launching in our
first version uh we're not doing model
optimization off the bat we're also not
doing drift detection off the bat
what what you need to do when you design
a platform is figure out how do I build
a system that adds enough incremental
value to where my autonomous data
science teams will want to use it where
they they get excited about the product
and they they see the value in it and it
solves a problem for them
um that Line in the Sand it will depend
on where the data science teams are what
problems they have and you'll you'll
have to figure that out through you know
your interviews with the different data
science teams what makes sense for your
organization but what what doesn't make
sense is to try to do everything in one
swoop and it'll come out bad that way
uh real quick on our testing release
strategy uh pretty standard stuff we've
just launched our beta version for spice
rack we're testing it with a handful of
internal teams right now on beta use
cases we're collecting feedback from
them that feedback is driving our
roadmap for the coming quarters it also
um is input to the templates that we
want to create for for all the data
science teams uh so that's a great way
to to develop templates is work closely
on with teams on specific use cases that
are very common for those teams
um and and after a while after working
with several teams you'll have a nice
little library of templates that people
can choose from
okay I think this is my last slide so
just a couple of points of advice uh
when heading out the door here so uh I
know I've talked about this a lot but
I'm going to keep hitting uh the the
nail on the head here that uh don't try
to build the Swiss army knife a build
for a specific use case with the team or
within a specific vertical it's not good
to build generically because you'll
probably build a lot of stuff that's not
needed or it'll become very expensive to
to build something
foreign use cases that are
representative of what your company does
to develop pipeline templates that will
really help accelerate your your team
don't over build or make your MEP too
complicated we want to start small we
want to keep building iteratively
under I don't talk about about this too
much in the introduction but you really
want to understand the model life cycle
the ml model life cycle and how your
users are are working and understand you
know at what point do they start using
your platform and their development life
cycle
um I think that's a very important thing
to understand
consider our multi-api approach with
high and low-level apis for different
users and different needs it's hard to
build something that's going to work for
everyone and one way to get around that
is to kind of slice the pie uh and and
sometimes you can do more than just two
uh sometimes three might be appropriate
but to identify the the major user
groups and address their needs with a
custom API for them
make it a strong communication plan so
even though these are internal products
and platforms uh you're still you're
still selling this thing and it's really
hard to force people to adopt a platform
you have to build something that solves
a problem for them that they get excited
about and then you have to keep
communicating that value over time and
just keep them engaged on what you're
working on
and one of the ways that we're doing
that uh at low fresh as we're we're
creating a mlaps council and the idea
here is that we'll have different
representatives from different data
science teams across the organization
um both on the tech side and the product
side and it's kind of two-way
Communication channel right so we'll
inform them of what are the latest and
greatest things that we're working on
from our side and then from their side
they'll inform us of what are the new
models that they're working on and what
are some of the the new templates that
they would like to see in the future so
it'll help Drive our roadmap as well but
I think that's a good communication
channel in addition to kind of the
one-on-one engagement with different
data science teams across an
organization
and if you want to learn more about
building platforms there's a great
article called what I learned building
platforms at sticks fit Stitch fix by uh
Stephen Crockett
um very interesting article that hits on
many of the similar topics that I've
talked about tonight but it's uh kind of
a great strategic read if you want to
learn more about AI product leadership
and building these these platforms
so uh that's that's it thank you very
much for listening and I'm happy to take
any questions that you might have
so we do have some questions in the
question and answer
um
you could also
unmute Michael Lane
I'll let you moderate the questions and
we'll try to answer them as best I can
okay
uh
let's see
we have one towards the end uh can you
talk about the system tests that you did
use to ensure the models are working
properly
um
we are so we're rolling up beta right
now but we are incorporating some bdd
testing
um is is the plan
um but we're actually going to do more
and more of that uh in future releases
um we are a little bit light in that
area right now but a more interesting
time to kind of just get the tool out
there and get people using it before we
we uh have tons of automated testing uh
and our our
uh pipeline creation process
and then I just um I unmuted Michael
Lane because he was UF a few questions
so if you want to unmute yeah yeah
um I guess the I'm realizing from this
talk that you can't be very specifics
probably because of an NDA I would
assume
yeah exactly I can't
can't give away the secret sauce but um
courts over here over here in Atlanta
Anna so we can't be specific either
but we can talk about like little
general things so I understand where
you're coming from
do you have resources that you would
recommend for people who are starting in
this
to learn the principles that you've been
talking about on a more specific basis
yes I actually have a slide for that
that I had to skip due to time
constraints but I'll pull it up here
um here let's load this up
and that'll basically summarize all the
other questions that I asked yeah
um I I kind of mentioned this very
quickly on the intro but there are many
good resources from you know the big
cloud providers gcp AWS and Azure
um everyone's you know trying to sell
their services obviously through these
white papers but you know most platforms
have the same or very similar type tools
so if you just abstract away the the
tool names and focus more on the
principles that they're talking about I
think uh you know you can Google these
these uh three titles right here and
you'll find some good stuff this gcp one
is very good it's pretty in-depth pretty
heavy but um
but but a good resource what I find is
available out there there's a lot of
technical learning about
um you know about ml apps but
there actually aren't that many uh
information sources about what I talked
about tonight about you know the really
the product management of it and uh
strategic decision making around uh how
do you build these systems correct
that's not very well documented so I
only know one vendor who actually does
it and did they do like your community
Meetup so yeah correct yep
but uh I think another good resource is
that last article that I pointed to as
well uh the Stitch fix article I can
pull it up here again what I learned
building platforms at Stitch fix if you
Google that
um it's a pretty long long article but
it's a good read
thank you yep
anything else
okay well
um yeah I guess if any no one else has
other questions thank you so much Dr
Whitman that was a really exciting talk
and again we'll have the link to the
YouTube video out on our page and keep
an eye out for our next next month's
meeting around the end of the month the
last Thursday in the month and yeah have
a good night yeah and I'll I'll add
um I'm going to co-publish an article
it'll probably be out next week with um
our feature store partner techton
um I'll be publishing that on on
LinkedIn it'll be up on their their
website as well
um they'll be a more detailed article
about just how we went through that
feature store uh selection process uh if
you're interested in learning more about
that
cool thank you so much
all right thank you everyone bye-bye
good night